[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM MORELLO: I didn't
trust teachers.
I didn't trust politicians.
I didn't trust people
on the evening news.
I trusted music.
The language of my life is
written in rock and roll,
and punk rock, and hip-hop.
[SOUND EFFECTS]
I'd like to teach a class
that makes your guitar playing
meaningful to you.
I'll show you ideas
in chords and solos.
I'm going to go through my
entire arsenal of guitars,
amps, and effects pedals.
You practice technique
to get your fingers
to go where you want them to go.
You practice theory to
understand where they can go
and why.
Rock and roll is a
visceral experience
and a connection with
the audience that
should be exciting at its core.
[MUSIC - RAGE AGAINST THE
MACHINE, "KILLING IN THE NAME"]
(SINGING) And now you
do what they told ya.
Those who die are justified.
For wearing the badge,
they're the chosen whites.
They're justified,
those who died.
For wearing the badge--
I was the only black
kid in an all-white town
and the only heavy metal
musician at Harvard University.
In a world that can be cruel,
and is sometimes racist,
and is grossly unfair,
all of a sudden--
[PLAYS GUITAR]
--with this thing
on, I'm invincible.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this class, you will
be able to write a song
and play a guitar solo.
Then we rock, even if you've
never touched a guitar before.
And for the advanced
player, the sky's the limit.
If you want to play
exactly like me,
you're going to figure that
out in this MasterClass.
If you want to play
guitar exactly like you,
I'll reveal how you can create
a lifetime of awesome rocking.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
I'm Tom Morello.
And this is my MasterClass.
[FEEDBACK]